Sambhaji manager Logan okay you're in
need to em on mute
you
today it is the appointment of a chair
in normal circumstances in terms of the
terms of reference for the committee the
chair would now actually be taken up by
a counselor from Derbyshire Dale's
District Council so can I have any
nominations don't--all it used you wish
to make a nomination elite oh yeah um
well I'd be very pleased to nominate
Chris furnace that's the furnace if he's
willing to stand - do we have a seconder
for that members I was a collector okay
can I have an indication of members
comfortable with them
yeah all in favor
okay thank you very much councillor
fairness will you now assume the chair
thank you
that's the furnace you'll need to Amelia
Mike
yeah Thank You counselors gadgets ask
Alan are you keeping a list of people
who we waiting to speak yes actually
sort of try keep an indication of who's
actually the green light and then I'll
sort of indicate to you right thank you
very much okay so item two is the
appointment of vice-chair which I think
this year is from North East I'll be
sure is that right that's right chair
the office of District Council would
normally take the vice chair at this
point so can I please have a nomination
for Vice Chair from northeast Council at
8:00 you wish to make a nomination
sorry counselor take your microphone
needs to be unmuted
that better that's better thanks there's
only is it just me and you Jeff
they're here today you would however be
able to nominate counselor whiter in his
absence if members come yeah I think
I'll nominate I'm so wired can we have a
seconder for that can please
well in that case our second counselor
white maybe that's all right Ellen yes
cuz the wiser
II
[Music]
or sat down so I have no idea what that
was chair my fave that might have in
someone's phone
okeydoke so I get that then that was by
consensus members are comfortable with
the vice-chair as council wise head
thank you okay thank you
item 3 apologies for absence Alan yes
I've received apologies for councillor F
richly who may be a little bit later
arriving at the meeting but he does hope
to be here in due course thank you thank
you I'm sorry err councillor them lilies
wants to make a point
yeah just to let you know before until I
wouldn't it's the meeting is still in
progress I left early it's at the time
of around twenty past three because I'm
like totally virtually having a prelim
not to do am i drooling a little
although one of the circumstances we
can't attendee it is going out on
podcast so I will believe in a twenty
plus three is the latest doing that but
guest councillor Tate as well chair near
quiets apologies please okay thank you
very much next time to piss any
declarations of interest from counselors
a nun received her good good
so item 5 is the minutes of the last
meeting assume everybody's read those Oh
are they is everybody ain't got any any
points to raise on the meetings or think
there's anything being missed or I did
point out one that the the Chairman
hadn't actually been named at the last
meeting but I think that you're ready to
alter that Ellen will actually record
that in these minutes chair yeah okay
Matt Brown Salter yeah thank you if
there is reference on page 7 and page 8
& 9 of my post when it should be the
joint ICT manager Nick's previous post
you
we'll actually make that amendment and
read it into today's minutes thank you
very much any other points to raise from
the minutes
No can somebody please propose that we
accept the minutes that's there with the
amendments this building
thank you come here second please I'll
say Cussler finesse I'll second that
with the amendments thanks counselor use
see ants please to approve that
the majority on yeah that's a chair
thank you six is the appointment of
secretary of the committee
yes Jeff that would normally be under
the terms of reference the joints heads
of governance for Bolsover and North
East Derbyshire district council so the
suggestion is is that that officer be
reappointed to the post
oh hey do you need it well I think it's
a case really more of less members have
got any concerns about that by a for
acclamation that yours are comfortable
with that
okay so unless I booked three injections
to that we will assume it's passed okay
then no objections so the item seven is
the appointment of treasurer and again
last year chair and the approach taken
was that the section wore five wore
offices of bonzer sorry Bolsover
district council and northeast
Derbyshire district council should
jointly carry out the role of treasurer
and again it's suggested the same
process or the same position be adopted
this year and again by acclamation
unless members have got any concerns
about that the continuation should take
back face
anybody go that causes like things here
I said I would like to move that course
of action ok we need to vote on this one
now again if members are comfortable
with us and no one's actually got any
concerns about it then they'll fire
formation
okey doke thank you I can make
appointment of Auditor
is that the same thing yeah absolutely
chair a game in terms of the terms of
reference that role is taken by the
chief internal world of Derbyshire
Dale's District Council and it suggested
a game by acclamation that members
support the continuation of that
appointments do we have any objections
to that No
okay so we'll assume that two have been
approved okay future item nine is the
quarterly service report Nicky please
yeah hope you've all been able to read
the drinked ICT quarterly service report
for the last quarter and the last
financial year I'm sure you're all
familiar with the format's already and
so I'll just give you a brief overview
and opportunity to ask questions and
reports covering the period of January
to March 2020 regarding the number of
incidents and service requests we
received during the quarter and they
were particularly high with January
receiving the highest number of the
12-month period and March the second
highest the increase was partly due to
the major upgrades to servers and
virtual desktops during January and
February and additional requested you to
the corona virus lockdown and
facilitation of remote working during
March outstanding calls the number of
outstanding calls increased instead of
the anticipated decrease and this is
whilst focus was diverted to home
working requests there's a result of
corona business virus business
continuity this may rise again over the
next quarter and due to again to the
focus that's been on getting people out
of the building and also staff taking
leave which was postponed
so that they could meet the January
operating system deadlines regarding the
service level agreements despite these
increases there were no breaches in the
service level agreements during this
time however I think we will anticipate
in future months that they they will
breach the SLA due to the increased
workloads and resources that we've had
to divert to the coronavirus activities
and also because people are taking that
leave that was postponed regarding
outages
there was no priority one outages and
over the three-month period there was a
total of 30 priority to our teachers
nothing specific to comment on around
project resource and the percent
percentage time worked on projects did
decrease after January as some of the
major projects came to a close and
resource was being diverted during march
to corona related activities the average
percentage project time of the 12-month
period though was above the SLA at 38.4%
through
also goes through a summary of the major
projects some project resource has been
diverted to the chronal related
activities and all they've had to be put
on hold as the changes are high-risk or
difficult to continue during lockdown
period for instance getting consultants
on site has been difficult
we move on to the budget that was
overall an overall under spend of
nineteen thousand six hundred and
seventy six for the joint ICT budgets
this this understand has taken into
account the additional costs of the
restructure so they have been deducted
as well the under spends mainly farm
employee costs there was under spend due
to delays recruiting to vacant post also
staff purchased additional annual leave
and we didn't need to use the training
budgets last year because we got a cyber
security grant for training and provided
by the LGA which covered it and there
was an understand on the services that
was mainly general expenses in computer
equipment so there the variable aspects
of the budget
it was also income we didn't receive as
much income but that's again variable
depending on what services want overtime
to be recharged I think there's a sort
of question to the committee regarding
the understand whether you want that to
be deducted from the court warm charges
and for this financial year or whether
you want it to be retained and to be
reinvested into the service details on
any of the investment opportunities
would follow and we would get agreement
from yourself beforehand
I would I would love to be sustained and
using them in the fashion is mansion
Paden sorry I would move the second
option to retain it and reinvest in the
way you've mentioned okay
thank you and Weavin aren't the cost
savings plan currently we're
investigating moving northeast northeast
telephony to sip Internet telephony this
will provide some savings on the current
ISDN costs we've completed a tender for
a new joint internet connection which
will deliver cost savings of forty-four
thousand pounds per year and improve the
internet bandwidth
although this will not come into effect
until September 2021 next year so it
will result in some additional costs
during the overlap the new front
multifunctional device contract at
Northeast and bowls over will deliver
13,000 PA furballs over and proximately
9600 for northeast whilst also providing
increased coverage of devices
security breaches has nothing
significant to report and serviced 11
developments the new service structure
was implemented as of the first March
and the senior technology posts was
recruited internally in February we
secured five thousand pounds for each
authority from the LGA for cyber
security resilience and we've also
secured two training courses to
unapproved cissp which is security
training courses and for two members of
the ICT staff so that's a year six
thousand pound ground for that
does anyone else got any further
questions or queries any questions from
anybody and I've got a couple which I'll
be first and then sorting coming later
and as Karen Karen I just don't like
your advice on this retaining and
reinvesting the underspend
what's your view on that from outside
it's not that significant so I don't
think it um in terms of value it makes a
lot of difference and I would recommend
perhaps that if there are specific
projects that it could be invested in
that might be a reason to set it aside
for investment rather than to refund it
I don't if Nicki can come back on that
yeah I mean at the minute I haven't got
specifics but what I would propose is
that we could if we have got something
specific for that money extra money we
could come back to the joint ICT
committee and propose you know is this
what you want spend time
you
as I use thank you Jeff
just
question really and that is to do with
the the loading you said that the
loading on the on support was going to
be higher in the in the current court
than it was in the last quarter will
this have an impact on costs or is this
or will they will the the will there be
savings in other areas in projects for
example to accommodate the increase in
support and if it doesn't if it doesn't
mean an increase in cost is that is that
something that the the savings from last
year could be used to support
potentially and it would mean I seen by
getting more staff paying for more staff
or overtime I think at the moment it
we've we've perhaps we pushed the
resource towards the coronavirus
activities so unless project work has
been done but there are projects that we
haven't been able to continue because
they've been high-risk while everybody's
out of the building so I think it's
something we could potentially look at
perhaps if it was put towards staffing
costs
okay okay with that David yes thank you
very much any other questions
[Music]
council casserole
it's a it's just a recommendation that
perhaps ICT could go away and make
recommendations rare and that nineteen
thousand pounds and given everybody's
comments
I suppose it's really established in a
principle whether it's something
committee are accept enough and if you
are accepting of the principle and then
we can go and put some meat on the bone
so to speak and make recommendations how
best to use that and obviously at that
time if if you then choose not enough
money then we're only delaying decision
rather than make an alternative one
apology new council abroad and I'm sorry
Alan yes please meet just to remind you
that I think actually would be a case of
the committee actually making a
recommendation in terms of the three
executive parts of the three authorities
in terms of how they felt that the money
should be used rather than something
that you can actually definitively
decide as a committee thank you you see
would could be a decision to recommend
rather than
take action
I've got another just a question about
Nick if I come back to you on the the 90
thousand pound redundancy charge that we
that we had or what are we on track now
to have that I think the years set was
2025 when we should have covered it are
we only well on track for that I was led
to believe that that had been taken and
I may need to come back to you on that
and check that that was only that it is
the full amount that's been taken
because I wasn't privy to what the
actual amount was so I would have to get
Forex on that one okay
any other questions
[Music]
okay this is something we need to vote
along this Alan I think actually the
recommendation is to just note the
report but I'd suggest it was note the
report and in particular and that
chunked ICT service will now actually
come fall with some specific ideas and
possible recommendations for how any
underspend might then be used yes okay
actually wanting to say
zonkers that's fine because that can
then go back to individual councils
country
yeah I think that would be the RJ that
sort of that there'd be proposals which
you as a committee would consider or
actually be comfortable with which could
then go back to the individual
authorities that's good do we need to
vote on the recommendation or do we just
pass it through as its to note again our
members feeling comfortable and with all
I think the issue about the votes is
were only really if actually members
actually feel that there is actually a
difference but from what the discussions
gone so far it would appear that
everyone is comfortable with that and
good members just indicate if they're
they are comfortable
okay thank you yeah good my case sure no
to those their comments
good Thank You Ellen so a movement [ __ ]
again to you okay video thank you and
yeah this report was sent out just to
sort of explain really to update the
council's on the background for issuing
the members protocol for the use of
video and audio conference in to join
official council related meetings and it
was recently sent out to Northeast and
bowls over members and a few weeks ago
to Derbyshire Dale's members by the head
of corporate services I haven't included
copies as they are slightly different
for each and a Mac might lead to come
some confusion similar guidance has also
been produced for staff at all
authorities for the same reasons as
highlighted in the report this was
agreed by CLT and Samet basically the
reasons for it is since lockdown ICT
receiving numerous requests to join
video conferences August organized by
third parties such as Chesterfield boy
council County the dodge partnerships
parishes etc and they're all using
different video conferencing platforms
such as zoom Skype teams WebEx goto
meeting and there is no standard tool
the different tools requires require
different software they have different
security and data protection
implications they're all cloud-based and
it makes it very difficult for ICT to
straight how they are used or what they
are useful or by who a risk assessment
in appendix 5 highlights many of the
risks the practical
we can mitigate the risks while enabling
virtual conferencing to support these
official council related businesses and
meetings is to either prohibit their use
or ask counselors and staff to agree to
a protocol abuses which determines what
they should or should not be doing
whilst using the different collaboration
tools although it doesn't fully address
all the risks through the member and
staff acceptance of the protocol the
authority can help to mitigate some of
the risks associated with the use of the
most commonly used video and audio tools
where technical constraints are not
available video and conferencing
technology is improving and maturing at
a fast pace and the protocol will be
reviewed regularly as it is subject to
change and it is envisioned that it will
form part of the ICT security policies
in the future the report also highlights
the difficulties with video conferencing
which is out of the control of ICT as it
relies on everybody's data connection
and whether it be 3G 4G or home
broadband regarding the council's
ability to support the network we have
recently awarded tender for a new 200
megabit joint internet connection to
assist with the council's connections
out of the authority's Network however
we were waiting timescales from the
supplier to install this so that will go
from a 40 mode connection 200 200 mega
connection and we've also started the
new project to review video conferencing
tools from mid term solution to conclude
we are requesting that based on the
reasons identified on in the report that
the joint ICT committee support the
adoption and acceptance of the members
protocols with the use of video and
audio conferencing tools to mitigate the
risks were using using those tools and
also that the joint ICT committee of
knowledge details of the report
including the associated risks and
mitigation so any questions or queries
okay I'm with you can I can I jump in
sure yeah thank you this is a detail
question so please please say if it's
too detailed for this committee the
there have been a lot of press reports
about security on zoom does do you have
any comments that you can make to
alleviate perhaps some concerns there
are overusing su and PCs and
particularly on the court only council
officers pcs whereas the members have
other devices which are are limited in
scope the council officers have are you
potentially using pcs which may have a
lot of confidential information on them
and I'm just a little concerned about
the use of zoom on devices with such
amount as such a large amount of
confidential information thank you
and we did do a report to see LT and Sam
about the use of scene but early on the
early days and we decided not to use
zoom at Northeast and bowled over or for
corporate devices we were going to use
the go-to meeting because of the
security issues that it had at that time
because of data privacy issues data
protection issues file sharing etc we
suggested using to go to meeting
platform for all corporate devices and
rather the presume
she does that they prefer to use zoom
for the council meetings which requires
that some of the staff also have it
installed on their laptops and we got
guidance probably about mid-april from
the LGA which was backed up by the
National Cyber Security Center they
recommended that the use of zoom for
official not official sensitive official
meetings was acceptable if it was
licensed which is the pro or the
business licenses were purchased by the
people who host meetings and that they
were set up with a specific set of
guidelines now we assist the Derbyshire
Dale's to set those guidelines orb and
to purchase their account so that they
were in line with what the NCSE and the
LGA guidance was at that time since then
things have moved on obviously
progressed a hell of a lot since and
zooms paddies is doing its 90-day sort
of towards the end of its 90-day
security improvements and there has been
a lot of improvements that we've seen
the paid for accounts you can restrict
which data centers they go through so
then providing the person hosting the
meeting has a probe license they can set
that it only goes through European data
centers which assists the data
protection issues and as of the 1st of
June today I believe they've stopped
using the old apps on the version 4 apps
and the version 5 apps now have the
end-to-end encryption which was
something that zoom didn't have before
so hopefully that answers your question
and by all means I can continue if
there's anything else you want to all
you want to bring me separately
no no that's fantastic and answer thank
you very much that was very
comprehensive and covered all the points
that I was
I was concerned about thank you very
much okay Sheila questions
that looks like kids so the
recommendation is that we this committee
supports the adoption and acceptance of
the members protocol the use of video
and audio audio conferencing tools to
mitigate the risks with using video and
audio conferencing would somebody like
to propose that sure
q and do we need to vote on that talent
clusters been moving on a secondary
suggests yes yeah okay
Oh raise your hands if you're in favor
please
unanimous Allen councillor Stolte voting
on this occasion it's it's fairly
majority anyway Chad the MU R the
motions past which is unanimous yeah
sure thank you very much okay so we'll
move on to item 11 corona virus outbreak
service response
I've got Nicky and Matt for this who's
going first
I could go first okay I think most of
its probably coming from me and yeah
since I'm a recap he seems like a long
time ago now I'm sure it does for
everybody and but yeah when the Korean
virus a outbreak well it was just before
obviously the lockdown occurred and we
were we were aware that there was
potential that that people wouldn't be
able to work in the offices and so we
focus resources on providing staff the
ability where possible to work from home
initially insuring all key workers and
those identified as wonderful could
where possible work from home and
extending this to many staff as possible
to ensure essential services could
continue in service disruption was kept
to a minimum some could already connect
to the virtual desktops when working
remotely or from home however these were
size only to accommodate a percentage of
remote workers a lot of work was
completed to install additional
applications to the virtual desktops and
to maximize additional desktops
resources to ensure more people could
successfully successfully work from home
during the lockdown we also very quickly
implemented three new virtual private
network connections or VPNs utilizing
the fiber links at each of the three
sites in order to allow more people to
connect to the network from home as they
did not need a virtual desktop to
complete many of their daily activities
we have today configured and enabled
over 165 users to connect over the
Virtual Private Network we also deploys
an additional 90 laptops 60 working at
home phones redeployed 38 of the IG
level terminals to work home workers
updated 80 iPads with video conferencing
and the modern gov UPS purchased and
configured over 150 new swittel accounts
to provide the two-factor authentication
for the virtual desktop users during the
outbreak we completed a lot of
additional work for sorry additional
work for the business centers that Kony
Green and tangent and this was just to
assist with their growing virus
activities such as businesses wanting
bone diverse etc putting on
we set up the technical and telephony
equipment for two additional call
centers for the community support
contact centers that bowls over
northeast and assisted with the creation
of coronavirus related forms we assisted
retinal homes in Derbyshire Dale's with
their telephony and provided assistance
to test Pilbara counsel to help them to
get the avato staff working on behalf of
their Derbyshire Dale's to work from
home just as lockdown was about to be
enforced focus was also very quickly put
on providing methods for staff and
members to collaborate in groups
remotely the main video and audio
conferencing providers were quickly over
evaluated such as Skype teams WebEx iam
and go team meeting
go team meeting was chosen as they
provided local authorities with a 90 day
free trial all those in also had free
accounts these accounts were limited to
40 minutes meetings soon at the time
also removed its phone option bounine
option as we knew that the iPads and
would had to come in to get the apps
installed and a lot of the microphones
have been disabled for security purposes
on the laptops and the phone an option
was an essential requirement there was
also security and data protection issues
that spoke about before so goto meeting
was very quickly rolled out staff with
managers and pas being able to given
instructions and accounts in order to
organize meetings it's been successfully
used to allow remote collaboration
between staff members and external third
parties during the lockdown period at
northeast ICT set up the camera and
streaming service in the council chamber
along with go-to meeting which has been
successfully used for several cabinet
meetings and a full council meeting a
similar setup is in progress at balls
over that Derbyshire Dale's ICT assisted
democratic services to set up their zoom
accounts to enable them to do their
council meetings
Joey lockdown we've we have maintained
one member a service desk at each of
them four main sites provide cover for
those still on site all other members of
staff have been productively working
from home
covering the service test phone remotely
fixing incident service request changes
and continuing project work and only
coming to site when necessary that's any
questions or Matt would you like to add
anything thank you nothing for me really
little confused with why I was on the
agenda the missile okay however without
the opportunity to say everything that
nikki is just sad it's easy for us to
sit here and just expect these things to
work and that's certainly I think the
challenge that staff have and certainly
ICT service have jumped up and met that
challenge really because the expectation
is to be able to walk off site go home
log on and work from home and there is a
lot more as you've just heard behind the
scenes that make all that happen and
whilst it's being done spending very
little money and lots of effort from
everybody to make it work there is some
consolidation to do there is some things
to perhaps make more permanent as
changes such as home working on virtual
meetings are probably a permanent
fixture in some form or another so there
is some work to do I think it's just
credit to Nikki and Kristen and the
whole of the ICT team where they were
really pushed down I'm sure Karen has
got similar stories from
dabka dolls as well
well I'd just like to step in and say
thank you to you both of un and all the
team really but all the huge Effie you
put in I mean it's been a very difficult
time for everybody but the extra work
you got to do is really been obviously
pretty tremendous and thanks again for
that are there any questions from
anybody else or points to me
just like there might be comments here
with regards to that's just me so what
Nick is just informed as up I think one
of the hardest parts of this and besides
what's going off in this monstrous will
Weber at this moment there is getting to
grips with this new technology and I
think the teaching part of it and in
particular from the northeast herbs your
point of view the role of math in
Derbyshire has been invaluable and I
would like on behalf of this committee
to say thanks to them people keep up the
good work and I'm sure all the members
at northeast Derbyshire will think the
same thing I know and throughout the our
partners that both of both mother and
omission deals have had to go through
the same process so I think I could roll
that out to all three organizations
yeah thanks very much anybody else want
to add anything or add any questions
Karen are you going to anything to add
on luck yeah I just like to add to what
Matt said and there's the service that
we've got from ICT Ishida's was
invaluable and there was barely any you
know disruption to a lot of services and
because they were able to get the extra
functionality to allow a lot more people
to work from home and I would like to
personally thank Nicky and Kristen
because I'm sure members will remember
and they hadn't longer taken up their
new positions and when they outbreak
struck hope so it really was a baptism
with failure and I think they did a
really good job to keep us all on track
thank you thank you I think you've got
the message you know how appreciative
they are of what you've done thank you
very much anybody else would like to add
anything before we finish this item
so there's nothing to vote on their own
is there it's just just report we've
heard so the next item is 12 urgent
business
yes chair just actually to say that
counselor heard he's been in touch she's
having difficulties logging on to resent
him the access details unfortunately
it's not worked so we'll just try and
sort of do better next time so I think
if members are come through this our
readers apologies into the minutes yes
please please do
so the final item is the date of the
next meeting which I guess will be what
September time will it
yes chair in terms of northeast are be
sure and also ver there's been a known a
turntable produced which is identified
two dates for possible joint ICT
meetings but the first of these would
actually be on Monday the 5th of October
at 5 p.m. at 2 p.m. and one D the end of
February 2021 at 2 p.m. so the question
is is that F members actually
comfortable with that we could then also
then press ahead with arranging one
further meeting after that towards the
end of the year which actually then
brings us to the four scheduled meetings
that you indicated that you'd like to
take place so to get one day 5th of
October at 2 p.m.
yeah
and one day 8th of February again at
2:00 p.m. with one further meeting which
would need to be arranged well say
instead a second one again please leave
yes sorry Monday 8th of February 20 21 2
p.m. yeah ok I'll bet all those dates
okay with everybody
anybody got any problems with that
No so I guess you'll be circulating
these Allen at the appropriate time will
indeed chef so if there are any problems
you know it can slip early on anybody
else not here has got problems we can
note perhaps rearrange
okay well that closes the meeting thank
you very much everybody thank you sure
by